is it a good idea for a filmmaker to
pitch a distributor their idea before
they pitch
an investor their idea excellent idea
it's the best idea i'll tell you why
because if they can get a distributor
interested it'll make the pitch to the
investors so much easier
because a smart investor they're going
to ask the first question they're going
to ask is not what's the movie about
frankly they don't care they're going to
ask how are you going to sell it and how
much you're going to make with it
that's what investors care about it's
called return on investment roi
all right so if the answer to that
question is funny you should ask that
because
i actually have a distribution deal and
i've got sales forecasts here and this
is what we think we're going to make
from it from this legitimate distributor
who's been in this business for 25 years
and knows what they're doing
that is a super compelling pitch to an
investor
way better than oh we're going to find
that out and i'll let you know here's my
guess
it's the way to do it and so a
prospective indie filmmaker will do what
they'll
find a list of distributors in their
niche
they'll email very brief email
saying here's my idea i mean how do you
do how do you pitch someone
before you even have the filmmaking yeah
this gets tricky
this is called put on your dancing shoes
and and
uh or some people call burning the
candle at both ends
where basically you're gonna
tell your distributor your potential
distributor
what you sort of already have
and you're going to tell your investor
what this distributor sort of is going
to tell you
you're i don't it's not you this is
salesmanship
all right this is this is the art of
pitching and
and developing and selling all right
so you're an investor and you want to
hear
that a distributor is already interested
because when you hear that you'll be
more interested
but now you're a district you're a
distributor
but you don't really care about the
guy's investor what you care about is
did you make the movie yet
so basically what you want to hear that
you're going to make a
really good movie and this could be
something so you almost have to say to
the distributor
in some ways you just have to fess up
and you have to say look
i haven't made the movie yet but i'm
going to make this kick-ass
great movie it's going to be fantastic
and you have to go into a lot more
detail unless they ask you about that
um i think you'd be the right
distributor for it i'm not asking you
for any guarantees right now
all i'm asking you for is to ex
show me in writing express some interest
that i've spoken to you
and that this is could be something that
we would be interested in after you make
it that might be you know valuable and
if and if it's as good as you say it's
going to be
it could generate 2 million in sales no
commitments
very airy fairy language very very light
it's not any type of legal document that
you could ever
finance or rely on or anything but it's
better than not having it
at least it's you the investor sees you
made the effort to go to the
distributor to have the conversation to
at least get into the ballpark to at
least
get an understanding and they'll feel
more confident with that
so theoretically you have two phones and
you're running back and forth
not theoretically for real for real okay
yeah for real that's what you're doing
and you're
you're i call it the dance you're doing
the dance
and you're dancing at two parties at the
same time and hoping that you don't fall
over
but that's what everybody does i mean
that's how it's not just the film
business that's how a lot of projects i
mean
biotech you know you know high tech all
this a lot of stuff gets financed that
way
because you got nothing right you got an
idea unless you have a track record
you know then who are you you got a guy
with an idea or a girl with an idea who
just
you know has a vision people can't buy
into that so you have to start really
slowly and get make
tiny little steps both ways until you
can
that's why i say burn the counter you
got to just bring it closer and closer
and closer until
boom you got it jeff is this how you've
approached your previous film yeah i'd
say i'm a pretty good tap dancer
my wife would tell you that i'm not a
good dancer at all but she hasn't seen
me in business
she just sees me on the real dancer no i
know how to do the dance
um it's it's look at first of all
i would say i'm and i think anybody
who's dealt with me would say i'm a
pretty honest person
um so if somebody says hey you know
where you at with this have you made it
i'd say no i haven't made it it's an
idea
but until they ask me that it's going to
feel like it's not an idea it's going to
feel like it's
way more developed because you like you
need to hold people's hand through the
process
people who are very seasoned and know
all about it their walk in the park
but a lot of people aren't seasoned so
you just have to need to hold their hand
and get them over the hump
get them to share the vision and and it
really involves a lot of
finessing and and timing and
you know don't push too hard here don't
push it you got to push a little like i
said you got to make little steps each
way to get up to the thing
so that boom you can get what you want
done to bring
you know kind of two elements together
financing and distribution which are
closely related the revenue stream and
the cash flow those are very closely
related concepts and and you know
sometimes it takes a lot of juggling i
think a lot of
indie filmmakers fail at that i mean
it's very very difficult
to do that it's it's a bit of an art and
there are people who are really really
good at it as you've seen
and uh you know that's what investment
bankers do
frankly and that's what venture
capitalists do
they just bring ideas to life by
bringing parties together bringing money
together with
with sales why do you think a lot of
independent filmmakers fail at it
because they're too anxious they're way
way way too anxious and they jump the
gun a little bit
well first of all they don't know
distribution well enough so they don't
put enough weight on the sales side and
the revenue generation side
and they put most of it on the artistic
side so when they're
for the most part when they're pitching
an investor they're telling them how
good the movie is going to be and how
good it's going to look and it's going
to be fantastic and we'll be able to
sell it
i never start that way with investors i
always say
here's what the marketplace will bear
here's what we think we're going to do
we're going to
generate a million and a half dollars on
a million dollar budget or on this 800
budget the roi is going to be this oh
and by the way here's the movie
i've never had an investor ask me to
read a script i mean i'd give them a log
line
they don't care why should they care
they're investing in you your ability to
make a film and your ability to sell the
film that's what they're investing in
now the bells and whistles and the fun
stuff for an investor are
hey can i come on set can i do a cameo
can i read the script
can my kid be in the movie you know
that's the bells and whistles and that's
the icing on the cake and you throw all
that in because you know you want to do
some
the deal and make it fun for everybody
but the core essence of the investment
is
are you going to be able to deliver the
really good film that you said you can
and are you going to be able to sell it
and how do i know you can sell it
how do i know you can make it hopefully
you've
made some other stuff or you're
surrounded yourself by good filmmakers
or whatever that's the credibility thing
how do i know you're going to sell it
you're dealing with people who've sold
before
you have surrounded yourself in those
circles and
you know although we know it's a risk
it's not sold it's not pre-sold we know
there's a risk there
but at least you're thinking about it
and you're planning for it
that's a good thing which is what most
indie filmmakers don't do
because they don't like to do that out
of the seven feature films that you've
made jeff
how many times have you gone to the
distributor
first before you've gone to the investor
every time
i i i wouldn't go to an investor until i
have a distribution plan
there's no point in pitching an investor
unless you have
a complete plan of how you're going to
generate revenue because that's the
number one question that they
that they ask you and that's what you
have to lead with
it's an investment now but remember
this is a business for me right so if
it's a business for me it's a business
for my investors
i've never gone to uncle charlie and
said you know what uncle charlie
i'm dying to make a film and i need
somebody to pay for it and don't expect
to get any money i need a donation
i've never done that because that's not
what who i am and what i do
i've always gone to people and said
uncle charlie um
what are you investing in real estate
you know what are you making you're
making eight percent on your money i'll
show you a place that you can make 15
i got a film and here's the cash flow on
it and here's my revenue projections
and the reason you should believe this
is because i've distributed 50 other
films like this here's what the
marketplace looks like
and you know you can make some serious
money on this
and here's the time frame it's going to
take and here's how the cash flow works
and all this kind of stuff
and he says oh that's interesting what's
the film
most filmmakers say oh i've got this
great film it's a it's a
rom-com and it's going to be great and
it's going to start this and here's the
story and here's the plot lines and
here's the beats and here's this and all
the kind of stuff
and they never get to the roi and the
revenue because
you're an investor you're putting money
in now remember if you're looking for
the donation
do it differently if you're looking for
an investor who actually wants to make a
return on investment you got to
show them the investment you got to lead
with the money so i would
never even bother pitching an investor
until i have
totally mapped out the distribution and
revenue generation plan
and you know for the most part i
self-distribute sorry i able to do that
myself
um but there are cases recently you know
where
where i've worked on other people's
films where i have
mapped out their entire revenue
generation plan long before they've even
tapped into an investor
by the way there was a case one of my
clients and i won't name them
but if they're watching they know who
they are they came to me
and they said i've been pitching my
potential investor group
and they're not biting can you help me
and i said what's your pitch and they
showed it to me and i said you're just
talking about the film
if i was an investor what i would i
would have no interest investing because
you're asking for a donation here so
that you can you know make a film
let's rejig it and i said i i'll pitch
for you but you can't be there because
you're going to spend too much time
talking about the movie
and you're going to be aggravated that
all i talk about is the investment so
i went and pitched all of his investor
group
including all of his relatives like
we're talking you know parents all this
kind of stuff you know
and and um and just talked about the
money
and then and they said okay now it's an
investment before it was a donation now
it's an investment
thank you very much this makes sense you
sure you can do it
and i said yeah and i charged him a
pretty big fee to do it
and uh and i also arranged all his
distribution for him too which i also
charged a fee for
but because of that not only did he get
his financing but he actually made the
movie and he actually sold the movie so
it all worked out
people got you know what they bargained
for and uh i was pretty confident
that i could sell that movie and i
actually said
you know in some ways i kind of pre-sold
it the only reason i didn't pre-sell is
because i wasn't making it
so i had to make sure that he was going
to make the move that he could deliver
the movie that i was
negotiating for but my credibility's at
stake too so
i wasn't you know it was his movie not
mine i didn't have creative control over
it
so i was prepared to go a certain
distance but if he didn't deliver a good
movie i didn't want to take a
distributor's money
for a movie that wasn't good because i
have you know i have pride and
credibility too at stake
what's the time frame of getting
investors versus getting distributors
i do it simultaneously you do it at the
same time because
they more or less take the same amount
of time and then it's not a linear thing
it it's
it's a parallel situation so
basically as i'm pitching distributors
i'm also lining up investors and
pitching them
but i'm i've done the work that the
distributor is going to do for me
already
i've already done all the revenue
forecasts and all i need them to do is
sign off on them
so i'm already pitching the investors
saying that this is who it's going to be
or this is what the numbers are going to
look like and they say who's the
distributor
if i pitch early before i have a
distributor then i'll say well i'm
talking to these three
and i'm in negotiations right now but
we're all in the same area this is sort
of the numbers and i'll
line that up afterwards but at least i
have three on the table
and i might not i might have five i
might have two but you know
you just it's part of the the i
shouldn't call it the dance it's
it's part of the process you know it's
it's a real part
and and um you know you're gonna get one
like i know i'm going to get one in the
three
and i might get a bidding war and it
might be better than what what i have
pitched to them
but um they both need to hear
like the distributor also doesn't want
to gauge get engaged until they know
that you have financing to make your
movie
so when you say hey guess what i'm you
know i have a investor meeting tonight i
got you know six
investors coming to my house and i'm
pitching them and if you give me this
document there's a good chance i can
green light it and if i green light it
you're gonna get to distribute it so
there's incentive on that side also
where are you getting the information
for these forecasts
well again i get it because i've been in
distribution my whole life so i
i forecast it myself based on my own
experience and everything
you know what the key thing is i this is
what i've said this and i don't know if
this is even possible
but it would be a perfect world if
coming at a film school all young indie
filmmakers
got hooked up with a mentor an
experienced mentor that would be the way
to launch people's careers
because all the stuff that we're talking
about really comes with experience
the all the credibility comes with
experience you have to have made the
mistakes
so um but it takes years and years and
years to get there to make the mistakes
so
it would be more of a launch pad if an
indie filmmaker could come at a film
school
have their hand held by you know this
happens in like think of what doctors do
doctors go for four-year um you know
residencies
four years they get their hands held so
that you know because they
you know medicine doesn't want to put
somebody in the field until they're
super super confident that they've
already learned all this stuff right
what if we did that in filmmaking like
hooked these young filmmakers up with
experienced filmmakers
and had the experienced filmmakers
helped navigate all these challenges
getting a distributor you know pitching
to investors
you know maybe even helping them develop
or or you know teaching them how to
properly make their films on time and on
budget
this would be super helpful for indie
filmmakers who it's
very difficult to navigate that one you
don't know what you're doing
two you're not credible even if you
didn't know what you're doing nobody's
going to believe you know what you're
doing because you've never done it
before
i mean there's just these big hurdles
that you know that
you have to overcome that really come
with time
and so if you had somebody by your side
like you know experienced doctor holding
the hand of a resident
and making sure they don't make a
mistake but letting them learn on their
own
you know or letting them make a mistake
even and then correcting it afterwards
that could be super helpful so i don't
know how that could work but
that that's really what would be
great for in the film they they need to
they need to hook themselves up with
if they want to get a like a high budget
feature made like when i say a high
budget you know anything like above a
half a million dollars
which is in the hobby film which is a
real movie which is you know potentially
distributable and can get onto you know
a streaming service
they got to almost be connected with a
with an
experienced filmmaker so that they'll be
taken seriously
they could be a better filmmaker than
that experienced filmmaker maybe more
talented
but the experienced filmmaker has the
credibility from years of doing it and
knows how to
say the right things to the right people
in the right tone
and just can help them over those
hurdles otherwise you know you could
stumble and fall for a long long time
waiting a lot of lines you know never
get those distribution meetings
you know never really landed a true
investor it's it's tricky to juggle it
all
do you think in some ways though hand
holding prevents
it makes it too easy for people
sometimes it's good to help people
it prevents learning and it also doesn't
build resiliency
i see a lot of people that have had
their hands held they're not resilient
and they almost need some of these hard
knocks i think there could be a nice
combination of the two
i think there comes a time when you've
learned the lesson you've
you've fallen you've been gotten up by
yourself a couple times and you can just
use
a little bit of a helping hand there's a
balance there is a balance
because i don't think that the real
world there's not a lot of helping hands
and i'm not saying that it's totally why
don't we let doctors
struggle through it well that's a little
different because they're saving lives
well they're they're opening up
someone's aorta yeah fair enough i mean
no i don't i don't know if i want but
but plumbers
have like that means that's five-year
residency
things yeah they can mess things up okay
so filmmaker can't totally mess things
up but you know they
well yeah fair enough you know i mean
i'm not saying that it's not important
and you could say the same for
entrepreneurs as well
and and other businesses but sometimes i
think
too much hand-holding spoils people and
then they don't learn the right lessons
i
totally agree the school of hard knocks
is the best teacher i totally agree with
you
yeah but at some point you've been
knocked so many times and it's just
you just have to get over a hurdle and
once
you you've already you're appreciated
you appreciate that
you can't get over that hurdle without
some mentoring and then you get over it
and you get knocked around a little bit
more
there's a balance yeah i'm sure there is
it's that's what goes on in parenting
you just got to find that right balance
of how much to protect your child
and how much to let them you know fall
and stumble and get back up
yeah because in business there's there's
not a lot of
of heart and hand holding from the other
side correct okay but
only in the indian world in in the in
the studio world
everybody gets their hand held
everybody's protected everybody's got
these big crews and all these protection
mechanisms around them and nobody really
can fail by themselves so
they're in this very comfortable
environment you have to really mess up
to
on a you know in a big film crew or
whatever but
getting in that world is really tricky
right that's true but you know you're
talking about the entrepreneurial
world where you know you're out there
alone and
you i don't know i agree with you
but there maybe could be more of a
balance i mean what would be so terrible
after somebody stumbled and fall a few
times and says hey you know i just can't
get over this hurdle just to help them
over it and let them get on to the next
thing and hopefully they'll remember
that that they stumbled and fell and got
some help and maybe you know
yeah let's pass it forward play it you
know yeah that would be nice
you